[Musique]
ils viiie arrondissement de paris
les trois corridors de l'hôtel meublé du
quartier château d'eau des sapeurs
africain fin représentant de cet art de
vivre qu'est la sape s ape
autrement dit la société des ambianceurs
et des personnes élégantes une centaine
d'adeptes à paris est le premier du nom
devant notre caméra qui s'appelle
docteur liman et congolais comme il se
doit
musiciens airois des sapeurs une vedette
docteur pourquoi docteur parce que
j'aime la propriété
je soigne tout ce qui est bon je perde
tout ce qui est quand même 6 et c'est
pas cher mais ça soit ça flashe faut que
ça flashe il y a désormais le style
lyman a tenu à les loups ya là vestes
manteaux par exemple en somme conjuguer
les verbes porté vers soi même une
petite révolution seulement puisque les
sapeurs apprécie toujours de manière
superlative les criques de prestige
[Musique]